it's no cheese where it says it has
cheese cheese with tofu mm-hmm what the
[Music]
hell's going on everybody for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you from
decoy and red farm in the West Village
where I'm joined by the Chinese hip-hop
sensation higher brothers you know them
from hits like nomadic and made in China
and they just wrapped their first-ever
North American tour and that brings us
to New York City where Chinese food it's
a genre unto itself from the Cuban
Chinese joints on the Upper West Side to
the hole in the wall spots where you can
get chicken wing combos and spare ribs
so today what we're gonna be doing is
rolling out iconic New York City dishes
to see if they stack up to the higher
brothers highest of high bars and before
we get started I know that you guys are
just finishing up the North American
tour if you guys had a chance to eat
Chinese food in America and if so what
do you think
are you trying to always eat Chinese
food and Chinese difference it's okay
it's okay but not like the four wheels
on this road Chinese food it's like
American Way Chinese for ya the head
Chinese food just look like Chinese yeah
the inside is different we're making the
way from Chengdu but I know that New
York hip hop was very important to you
guys as influential can you talk about
the role that guys like 50 cent jay-z
NAS what they meant to you guys growing
on me and listen 50 cent and I watch his
movie get rich or die trying' that's my
first time understand
gangster culture what's the connection
is gangster with hip-hop music before
not hip-hop you need to change your life
yeah tiny baby aliens and big issues I
was a film about a piggy in Chinese I
watch this I know it's a legendary [ __ ]
is a story I made a lot of things I want
to do something like biggie so I try to
write some lyrics
I made a graduation are you guys ready
for the first dish yeah yeah all right
let's bring out some wings
oh hey so you guys like the reveal oh
wow
first up we have the famous chongqing
chicken wings from mission Chinese the
wings are spiced with the mixture of
sensual on peppers cumin seeds you have
some mushroom powder the dish also has a
honeycomb tripe these are not your
average wings suddenly you guys are
coming from Chengdu which has a
reputation for being on a regional level
place to eat very very spicy food how
big a deal is spicy food is so important
just like you just like Chinese eating
rice Chandu Chandu nice eating spicy
food every day should we try these wings
because these are a little spicy
oh that's too spicy
only slicing well close the table is it
too spicy is it not spicy enough is it
just right for me it's spicy for me is
to slice
are these spicier than what the wings
you'd get in such one so transpose a is
more for other tastes not only spicy but
you keep going in is that because you're
hungry is just like that right you can't
eat it too much but you can stop that's
right at the end everybody's also
specify you can stop your lips and ha in
your mouth every time yeah and then it
is just so delicious that you keep going
back and back and back for even though
it hurts more and more and more and more
just I'm like oh they love ya just like
love well you know I saw on the road the
other day that you guys were eating
Popeyes so I guess this is how we'll
deliver a verdict would you rather have
the Chongqing famous chicken wings from
Mission Chinese or Popeyes this sign it
seal it
stamp it mail it on to the next dish
bring in more spring all right very
excited for this one right here this is
the General Tso's chicken and waffles
from sweet chicken Brooklyn fried
chicken hotness sweet General Tso's
sauce and then lead on a rice and
broccoli waffle fun fact this spot that
we got this from it's co-owned by NAS by
NASA yeah and I feel like you guys are
already a fan yeah that's my favorite
way Americans breathe first ice cream
thank you I don't want to speak I can't
take this chicken the chickens a little
much no I mean just saw yeah
a little too much sauce on the chicken
I'm like when a dish gives you two
options so that if one of them bricks
yeah always that one that can save your
meal you know
Oh chicken laughs that's the bad
cheating is not cool you can either
watch alright so what we have here is
the ultimate Americanized Chinese dish
you know General Tso's chicken and
waffles I'm wondering what do you guys
think what's your take on this one this
is good top-2 choice whap it's cool but
uh the South I'm gonna champion bow
shape yeah
up next we have the Mapo tofu chili
cheese fries from king noodle king Ludo
king Ludo what I mean Potenza Moodle wet
noodle they're a thin cut french fry
topped with citron pork chili multiple
scallion and tofu when tofu which you're
a big fan of this is Jay wait I don't
fool it's no chase or e-excuse it has
cheese cheese with tofu mm-hmm what the
[ __ ] so this is the type of cultural
mashup that can either go really good or
really bad
what's your verdict here surprises goo
cheese doesn't go and tofu I love the
cheese fries but easily totally it's not
like I love the couch game but it's a
good camera mix when you have a
McDonald's tattoo on your neck how did
the fries stand up are these McDonald's
level fries as good not as good where
you stand on the fries I like the
madonna of french fries better than this
cuz there is code I like the hot spring
hot there you go little salt crispy yeah
not just mixed in with the tofu and the
cheese room temperature but don't worry
we have one more dish left let's say
vote me alone bring out one more dish
the last
dish let's take it home Lona last but
definitely not least we have the Katz's
pastrami egg roll from right here at red
farm and decoy they stir fried cabbage
peppers celery and oyster sauce and a
wok and mix it with pastrami from Katz's
the century-old jewish deli on the Lower
East Side and then what you do is you
double fry it right here and the tempura
batter to make it extra crispy and then
you serve it up with a honey mustard
dipping sauce that's how we do it boys
Jimmy's house trying to read between the
lines on all the deme with hand speed
well the hair brothers green and make a
noise really that's a good so this is
your first time eating pastrami drummy
it's the meat that you have in this
agony so this is made with meat that's
brined seasoned smoked and steamed does
it taste like anything that you grew up
eating in China and this tasted like
young Michelle ones yeah in China we
have a photo with koe de Jong Un's
octopus born about for some street foods
in China
yeah just like hotdogs on the street
yeah what we've had four dishes today
boys okay okay but I need to know is
your favorite one of the day everybody's
got to go down the line for me it's the
first one the spicy chicken wing you
like the mission Chinese wings
yeah like then for me it's less so on
very hot the eggroll hit the spot for
you yeah like I said yeah number one is
this I need a heart fool it's amazing
cheese price the cheese fries yeah so we
have the cheese fries we have the
mission Chinese we have the egg rolls
from Katz's and you know what I liked
the chicken and waffles from sweet chick
a little too much sauce but just like
you my man I to I on that it's my
favorite meal as well I feel you I feel
you same wavelength brother alright well
there you have it the higher brothers
and Shawn tasting iconic New York City
Chinese dishes did they jump over the
bar some of them some of them slammed
their head against the bar some of them
didn't reach the bar and some of them
did backflips over the bar and that's
why you got to try it and here we are at
the end you have to check out the two
EPs they're everywhere Journey to the
West and tight neither really and then
if you just want that good good New York
City Chinese food you have to come to
decoy and bread farm that's it from
Shawn that's it from the higher brothers
thank you for coming through my guy
thank you thank you
yeah until next time
[Music]
[ __ ] with a cop reason you swallow
chicken waffles my father you know what
the [ __ ] is going on bro I will finish
it all right now
believe me chicken and waffle that [ __ ]
with none